can we talk about this mlk fortnight
there yes please yes oh this is so funny
okay so fortnite basically does these uh
like virtual events no fortnight is out
yeah that i do yeah he's trying so hard
to be young like
i don't even play it's so hard you're
trying to be
[Laughter]
all right so basically fortnite does
these virtual events right where they
had like a traffic stop so you gotta
like build scaffoldings
i mean actually it is you're thinking of
minecraft but you actually do build i
think you build scaffoldings and then
you like do a lot of jumping and [ __ ]
that is true yeah yeah okay i thought
she was simcity no sim cities build like
actual like cities and [ __ ] like that
you don't know what is your bill
definitely played same thing [ __ ]
parachute in and [ __ ] like so many
systems
you steal dances from black kids and
then you do them in the steel is sharing
also
fortnite
and basically they do these virtual
events where you don't really like play
on the map but you can go and watch the
event virtually so they have like a
concert travis scott did a concert oh
dark ass
yeah
and the most recent one they did is they
did a virtual playing of martin luther
king's i have a dream speech
on the steps of the lincoln memorial oh
that would go wrong in fortnight that's
a lit so all these kids that don't even
know what the [ __ ] oh my god the i have
a dream speech is they're from they're
from portugal they're coming from
america they don't even know what's
going on yeah it's a global game okay so
they just pulled up and so the funniest
part of the whole [ __ ] so obviously like
kids are just like doing dances and [ __ ]
like in front of the memorial like he's
talking to his kids just [ __ ] busting
it out and then the best part is that
they took his dream though in a way is
white
kids holy [ __ ] that's a good point doing
black dances coming together holy chair
all right but then on top of that like
first off mlk was like a known pacifist
like he was a non-violence advocate he
hated the war in vietnam and he was a
socialist
and then literally fortnight is a
capitalist violence game
so i'm like i don't know
but it's not real violence it's a video
game you're killing people with guns
it's a video no but it's not real
violence so i wish that was actually a
setting where they got to you got to
dress up as fbi in the game
and then if you shot him okay lisa would
be accurate
i'm saying he was assassinated by the
fbi is that not true no
who oh excuse [ __ ] you old [ __ ]
yeah i told you wikipedia
by the cia i think they just let them
die i mean that was the issue you don't
think cia killed him who martin luther
king yeah nah i think he was killed by
uh lee harvey oswald
right james earl ray actually knows that
who is he killed by
right yeah the [ __ ] that played
uh
[Laughter]
at least i hit this so i didn't damage
you yo son this is where my face is i
moved it i did it on purpose i'm
literally my name is nice with it do you
see my hand if i didn't move the mic
that [ __ ] would have hit me right in my
face this guy's crazy bro you weren't
crazy
it's destroyed
it's for tonight
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it just sounded crazy because it bounced
off that damn and broke apart when it
did but how fast am i just to move it
out of the way so just no you did
actually have a shield i don't know if
you got a power off from getting a loot
box but you definitely blocked that
pretty good loot box
this is
hilarious okay
why that [ __ ] break so easy
no this guy's strong man that's what
happens i considered that though i
considered that monitor would be fine to
break
as long as i hit that monitor did you
miss allen purpose no
nah i tried it move it come on
yeah you did it
what historical event would you want to
see as a for a virtual fighter i want to
see that again
i want to see it that would be fire
actually where would i want to go for
virtual fortnite yeah what event you
want historically um
i would like to be at the play where uh
abraham lincoln was assassinated oh
that'd be a fire one that'd be sick
because you know there's a few people
that play like man they should be born
like they're like man something happened
bro why you always bring me this [ __ ] my
girl forced me to go this goddamn play
can something exciting happen please
and then seeing my man make the jump
you're like yo yeah that actually said
like that leap from the opera box was
probably kind of dope yeah the parkour
front flip it was the first parkour yeah
it was a front floor but then that was
like next level matrix like neo [ __ ]
yeah have you seen that oh that tv's out
was coming
it was the way i did
you are influential donald glover yeah i
know thank you donald dude why did it
give up now nothing else is happening
[Laughter]
why the whole [ __ ] gave up i don't know
what a bitch-ass tv what is that lg
because you blasted would you let's go
what did you throw at it
lipstick no you know that was lipstick
yeah
oh blistex or whatever you're doing you
know what this is
this is oh you are good son
this just reminded me of my broken ass
tv so you are good oh did we tell that
yeah yeah we did it right
please if anybody wants to swap out my
tv [ __ ] with your boy
i heard i heard there's even more
details no i heard costco can do it i
heard there's even more details to it
what
there's no new [ __ ] i heard some good
old [ __ ] bro eyes are good old [ __ ]
[ __ ] making people do his dirty
work
he wasn't even making a call to see if
he was a good idea guy
i need to get my tv working oh yeah
somebody make this happen you unless
someone else get arrested for you
this guy's a crazy mother okay anything
else from this fortnight yeah so the
craziest part is that
remember doing karaoke remember you
threw a hard thing at me
like you could have bruised my whole
head threw it at the mic i'm nice
protect my face yeah that's nice bro son
that was unbelievable timing
so because they knew that all these
fortnite kids were gonna go crazy
are you
[Applause]
oh my god oh my goodness i just put a
little a little lipstick on it
bro
you almost took his life you see where
it hits the light spot is where it hit
okay
playback
10 on the mic that's how hard you threw
that damn that's not for me good
they broke it
yeah of course you wish it hit him and
broke your [ __ ] mind
that's yeah
we don't even know if the cameras are on
anymore okay go go the camera might just
be playing the craziest part of this
fortnite mark's been trying to tell us
this for three years
before the podcast he's like we gotta
talk about this fortnite thing go go go
all right so because they knew all the
kids would be going crazy okay have you
ever played like an xbox live chat room
like you know that they need the [ __ ]
mlk speech but what they did is they
took out all the tomato vending machines
so you couldn't throw tomatoes and then
on top of that they took off most of the
dancing emojis but there's one that they
couldn't take off because it was a part
of like a dc promotional thing that they
were doing so they had to keep it on for
the month and it was catwoman's whip
no
there's no way
there's no
wow they're doing the mlk's no way
there's hundreds of kids running around
going i have a dream
and just smacking whips all over the
whole time i can't believe it's legit
crazy that no one thought that through
or they didn't call dc like yo maybe a
bad look for the game or the movie if we
don't do there's no [ __ ] way shift is
this real
why is catboy got a whip what does that
have to do with cats
they got long tails yeah but they don't
use them for whipping uh not yet
maybe swan flies with them and [ __ ]
right what long-ass tail yeah you think
they have like wolverine claws or
something yeah yeah i thought that was
her [ __ ] why does she have a whip
you gotta have something else i guess
i think it's a sexual thing
what's the sexiest weapon we could give
this girl yeah yeah yeah you're right it
was kissing a jerk off the movie came up
catwoman i guess i don't know apparently
they did catwoman or something i didn't
hear that so
yeah they had a collab with catwoman oh
my god so they couldn't take off her
whip so literally mlk's talk about
racial justice there's no
[ __ ]
way dude
yo fortnite's kind of lit yo it's lit
dude it's a whole game for kids where
you learn how to shoot people and you
jump out of a school bus wait why do you
jump out of school i don't know but but
that's what they thought kids in america
needed is like yo let's teach these kids
how to shoot people out of a school bus
we do need that [ __ ] to self-defense at
a certain point yeah
so i think they're responsible for all
the shoes and i miss this game how many
buttons you got to use
it's almost double digits
if you got to use the the ones that's
where your thumbs are on at the same
time
two joysticks once halo came out i was
done
done i'm out
i don't even think they had the
joysticks back then nah you had to use
one to move and then one to go up down
okay come out before 911 at the time i
was xbox first i don't know why you got
to make this a racial
you thing what i mean hey that's
9 11. yeah yeah that was that racist guy
bringing up 9 11 to me you know what i
mean for what out of nowhere right
indians had nothing to do with nothing
yeah you're not how do you not you don't
know anything about that
hey look i'm talking about you
floridians
that felt racial to me too
yo we gotta lose an mlk dude let's get
on fortnite right now
can we do the dances
never dog come on nope
yeah we're straight 33 we're streaming
bro we're streaming
this game
i'm 33 years old i'm gonna play [ __ ]
fortnite 2017.
say what it was the biggest game in the
world oh that's where ninja came from
ninja was playing fortnite yeah he was
he was he was the first nice fortnite
guy
[Laughter]
why do you have to build scaffolding
yeah he grew up in new york he's like
dude construction yeah like what it
looks like to me union jobs yeah yeah
are they getting the rent kickback or
something like they're doing
construction on the whole game it looks
like it's just scavenging like you're
just building scavengers and then you
get to the top and you jump off during
the training yeah it's just weird